SIMON ROGERS: Thanks
so much for coming
and welcome to
[INAUDIBLE] live stream.
My name is Simon Rogers.
I am the news editor at Google's
News Lab, News Lab at Google.
And we're working some really
exciting stuff around data
journalism at the moment.
Coming soon we have
the trends relaunch,
which is going to be amazing.
So today is a really
great talk for us
to have-- how to tell
stories with data.
And we are incredibly
lucky to be
joined by David
Leonhardt, who is editor
of "The Upshot," which is new.
How long now?
It's a year, a year and a half?
DAVID LEONHARDT: Just
about a year old.
SIMON ROGERS: Year
old and has already
become one of the foremost
practitions of data journalism
out there in the wild.
It's got great experience
about working with data.
He's also won a Pulitzer prize.
Is he the only person in here
who's one a Pulitzer prize?
I'm going to say yes to that.
And he's worked the
"Times" sometimes,
also before that at
the "Washington Post."
Has great experience
across the news industry.
So without further delay,
I'll go introduce David.
DAVID LEONHARDT: Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks so much for having
me, and for coming here
on a beautiful day, and watching
on live stream, and all those.
I've collaborated with a lot of
folks at Google over the years,
and so it's really
nice to be back and be
talking to all of you.
I want to try to give you a
little bit of the big picture
sense of journalism briefly, and
then we'll talk a little bit,
and then open it up to any kind
of questions that folks have,
whether it's about
data journalism,
the "New York Times"
generally, whether it's
about anything you want.
So let's start with
the big picture,
and I want to start by
asking a question, which is,
have you've heard the one about
journalism being in decline?
It goes something like this.
No one will pay for
serious journalism.
Listicles, dumb down
explainers, slideshows
about pets are replacing
in depth reporting.
Social media has
created an echo chamber
in which people read only
articles that confirm
their pre-existing biases.
The good old days of shoe
leather reporting are fading.
Well, this story is wrong.
American journalism is better
today than it has ever been,
I believe.
Yes, it faces some challenges,
serious challenges,
real challenges.
The nostalgic narrative is not
completely without some truth.
It has strands of truth to it.
Above all, the business
model of journalism
is changing rapidly
in a way that
does threaten some truly
valuable parts of the industry.
I worry in particular
about local news, which
serves a really vital
role in our democracy,
holding school boards,
and judges, and city
councils accountable,
keeping readers informed.
And we can talk a little bit
more about local journalism.
But it's important
not to confuse
the challenges that are out
there with the fuller picture.
The reason that journalism
matters, the reason that it's
different from, say, the
horse and buggy business,
is that it plays a crucial
role in our democracy.
It helps to keep citizens
informed about the world.
It gives them
information on which
they can act as voters, as
employees, as investors,
as researchers, or simply
as human beings who
need to eat, and exercise,
and sleep, and work, and play,
and make decisions
about all of this.
By this standard,
by the standard
of whether journalism is
keeping people informed,
I would argue that
journalism in 2015
is stronger than it was
in 2000, is stronger
than it was in 1990,
or stronger than it
was in those good old
days of 1950 or 1960.
It's more fun, both
to practice, and I
think it's more fun to read.
And I think there are four
reasons to believe this.
The first is that journalism
is more accurate than it used
to be, which is not to say
that it's perfectly accurate,
or to put it in terms that
an economist like Hal Varian
might use, the market
for truth is more liquid
than it used to be.
I want to show you
an article now.
This article appeared
in the "Washington Post"
a little more than 20 years ago.
It's an excerpt of
a story of mine.
It appeared in the
summer of 1994,
and it's about behind the
scenes political efforts
to build a new sports
arena in Washington.
It would become known
as the MCI Center.
Today it's the Verizon Center.
It's where the Warriors
play the Wizards
and the Sharks
play the Capitals.
I wrote this story at the
end of a summer internship
at the "Post."
And I will confess I felt
pretty good about it.
the paper stripped it across
the top of the metro section.
But there is a problem
with this story,
and I will ask if
anyone can see it.
I don't expect that
anyone will, but I'm
happy to be
pleasantly surprised.
The problem is that
there is a word that
is misspelled in this story,
and it's not just any word.
It's Katharine, as
in Katharine Graham,
the woman who ran
the "Washington
Post," the newspaper in
which this article appeared.
Katharine should have two A's
and one E. As you see it here,
it has two E's and won A. I
learned about this mistake
about a week later when I picked
up a copy of the Washington
"City Paper," which is
Washington's local weekly,
and there was a small item
in it, which read, I quote,
"there is a special place in
the dungeon of the "Washington
Post" for David Leonhardt,"
which is not exactly what you
want when you're a summer
intern trying to get hired.
I did not get hired.
I don't know how much it had to
do with the spelling mistake.
Now, imagine that I
made this mistake today
rather than in 1994.
Think about how different the
whole experience would be.
The story would go online,
and in all likelihood,
within a matter of
minutes, certainly
within a matter of hours,
some eagle eyed reader
would begin mocking me.
It would not take an
extra week to do so.
In fact, there is
a very good chance
that this never would
appear in the printed
edition of the
"Washington Post,"
because the article would
go online at 9:00 AM,
or 2:00 PM, or 5:00 PM.
We would see it.
We would feel stupid
about it, and we
would fix it before the
paper ever went to press.
Now, I know that
spelling mistakes
aren't really important.
They may be embarrassing, but
they're not really important.
But this newly liquid market
for truth is important,
and it's important
for reasons that
are much bigger than
spelling mistakes.
In the old days when
readers or sources wanted
to question the conclusions
or facts in a story,
they didn't have
many great options.
They had to write a letter
to the editor, which
might or might not have
been published days or even
weeks later, or they had to
persuade another newspaper
or magazine to write
an article that
came to different conclusions.
Today, writers and readers
are able to hash out
big questions in real time.
They're able to debate
them before the article has
settled into the consciousness.
To take a tiny example,
just this weekend
a journalist tweeted
an article with a chart
showing the Bureau
of Labor statistics
series on college costs.
I bet you've seen a
version of this chart.
It appears in the
media all the time
showing how college
costs have outstripped
nearly everything else.
That Bureau of Labor
Statistics series is wrong.
It is based on a
version of college costs
that did not include financial
aid until relatively recently.
I responded saying that Bureau
of Labor statistics series
is wrong.
I sent a link explaining
how it's wrong.
The journalist wrote
back, and said thanks,
and deleted the tweet.
This newly liquid market not
only is better for readers,
but it makes us
better at our jobs.
As the great psychologist
Danny Kahneman says,
"acquisition of skills
requires a regular environment,
an adequate opportunity
to practice,
and rapid and unequivocal
feedback about the correctness
of thoughts and actions."
With the exception
of unequivocal,
I would argue that
that whole definition
applies to social media in
particular and journalism
today.
The second reason to feel
good about journalism
involves the tools
and techniques
that we have for
telling stories.
If you'll permit me a
second brief personal story,
I joined the "New York
Times" in 1999 as a reporter.
I'm happy to report
in my 16 years
there I haven't I
haven't misspelled
Arthur or Sulzberger,
and many of the stories
that I write or edit
today have a lot
in common with the stories
that I wrote in my first months
at the "Times."
They're based on an academic
study or an analysis.
I try to understand the data.
I talk to other researchers.
I talk to policymakers about
why the study might or might not
matter.
I look for real people
who typify the trend.
None of that has changed.
Nearly everything
else has changed.
When those stories went
in the paper in 1999
when I joined the
paper, they likely
would have been accompanied
by one or two photos
and one or two black and
white charts or maps.
Today we have so many more
tools at our disposal,
and when done right, as my
colleagues are able to do-- I
do not have the technical
skills to do it--
those tools are
really, really good.
Consider this story from 2013.
This is about how the
odds of escaping poverty
differ depending on
where you grow up.
Gone is the little
black and white map
that would have accompanied
this story in 1999,
and if you had
squinted back then,
you might have noticed that
Utah was lighter than Georgia.
Today, you can zoom in on every
metro area in the country.
You can hover over
it, and you can
see what the odds
of a child who is
in the bottom
fifth of the income
quintile growing up to
be in the top fifth.
You can see that those
odds are vastly worse
in the southeast and the
old industrial Midwest
than they are in
most of California,
or most of New England,
or the mountain West.
You can also scroll
down, and you
can decide what income
group you want to focus on.
By any definition, this
is better journalism
than we could have
done even 10 years ago.
It gives readers more control.
It lets them understand
the data better
than they could in the past.
Now consider this
follow up, which
we ran just a few weeks ago.
It's based on the same set of
academic research, an updated
version of it.
It gets more detailed.
It goes down to
the county level,
and what my
colleagues did here is
they set up the journalism
so that wherever you log on
based on the best we can
tell from your IP address,
it focuses on that county.
I did not have to put
Santa Clara up here.
It came automatically.
Not exactly right.
Are we in Santa Clara,
or are we in San Mateo?
AUDIENCE: Santa Clara.
DAVID LEONHARDT: We are.
Exactly right.
Not only that, but
if you then read it,
you'll see the text actually
gets into Santa Clara.
There's a template in which
we give you data and text that
talks about Santa Clara.
I think by any
definition this is better
than we could have
done several years ago.
Here's another example.
We were looking at the
relationship between family
income and whether a
child goes to college.
The line is remarkably
straight, but we
thought showing people
a straight line would
underestimate just how
interesting it was,
so we invited them to
draw a line themselves.
Most people drew something
equivalent-- something
like an S like that, and then
we told them what it really was.
[LAUGHTER]
So basically that was
not a very good line.
80% of people did
better than I just did.
The real line is straight.
We then show people
that combined
answers that all readers give.
This is really interesting.
The situation is depressing.
Your family income
has a huge impact
on whether you go to college.
It's not as depressing as our
readers think it is, though.
Look.
Nearly all readers
underestimate the chances
that poor kids go to college,
and many overestimate the odds
that rich kids do.
The point about all of these is
that they literally could not
have existed in
1999, and whatever
you think about any individual
one, whether we did it well
or whether we could
have done it better,
they clearly have the potential
to be better than what
we were doing in the past.
They also have the
potential to improve
what I think remains the
highest form of journalism--
the expose that requires
enormous work, whether it is
on nail salon
workers in New York,
to cite a piece a
colleague of mine
has recently done, whether
it's on police killings,
to cite some work the
"Washington Post" has recently
done, it can make that
work better and easier
to understand.
One more example.
This comes from
election night 2014.
To be honest, election
night coverage
has long been terrible.
The media has exit poll results
it won't share with readers,
and it generally
reports raw vote totals
in a way that doesn't
explain that they
don't come in randomly.
In some states like
Virginia, Republican areas
report early and
Democratic areas late.
In other states like
Iowa, the reverse is true.
So some colleagues
of mine realized
this was possible to do better
on, and what they did was
they created an
expected vote return
for every county in any state
with an important election
in 2014, and they then
compared the results.
So if a county in Virginia was
coming in 70/30 Republican,
but it usually came in
75/25 Republican, that
doesn't mean the
Republican is ahead,
that means the
Republican is behind.
On election night, this
was actually going live.
We froze it at the end.
And so over time, the solid
line were the actual returns,
and the dotted lines were
our adjusted returns.
And I can tell you
since no one had ever
done this before publicly, it
was quite anxiety producing,
because by 8 o'clock, we
were already telling people
that Mark Warner
was likely to win
a narrow victory in Virginia.
That's the dotted blue
line that you see,
whereas the raw
vote total still had
Ed Gillespie, the Republican,
up by seven or eight points.
And we were all
hoping against hope
that the red line would
come down to the blue line,
not for partisan reasons--
in fact, I'll show you Iowa.
It's the flip-- because we
would have looked silly.
And sure enough, these things
could go wrong sometimes.
Wrong isn't even the right word.
Sometimes there's
going to be uncertainty
over the course of the
night, but the straightness
of this blue line I think
provide some pretty good
evidence that this is a better
way to think about vote returns
than the raw returns.
You'll see the opposite
in Iowa, as I mentioned,
in which the Democrats starts
with a pretty substantial lead.
The dotted line is
the adjusted line,
and it remains quite
straight all night.
These interactive real
time approaches to news
have all kinds of potential.
For sports coverage, my
colleague, Kevin Quealy,
did this delightful
NFL playoffs simulator,
that if you ask
a question about,
I'll be more than happy to talk
about-- about personal finance,
about all kinds of things.
I want to make one
additional point
about the new storytelling tools
that we have in journalism.
One of them isn't new at all.
It's the new variety of
voice that journalism
has always had at it's disposal,
but too often hasn't used.
And the reason we're
getting better about voice
is because of the informal
and direct culture
of internet conversation.
I've been a journalist
since I started
writing for my high school
paper almost 30 years ago.
It's the only professional thing
I've ever done in many ways.
So I offer the following
critique in a loving way,
but a lot of the traditional
style of news writing
is just not very good.
It consists of dense
complex sentences
that begin with phrases like,
in a fundamental shift that
has the potential to alter
the political landscape,
and then continues
for 40 more words
with various dependent clauses.
The web has helped to
break us of these habits,
or at least it's starting to.
We now more frequently write
in a conversational voice,
an understandable
style that allows
smart non-experts to engage
with our material more easily.
This change isn't revolutionary.
None of us invented it.
Kate Boo, Michael Lewis,
Robert Caro, Taylor Branch,
other great writers have been
writing this way for decades.
"Slate," which is a forerunner
of today's journalism
in so many ways, has
been doing it for years,
but I'm happy that
more of us are now
attempting this approach rather
than the stultified approach.
And let's be clear.
There is nothing inherently
sophisticated or smart
about a 40 word sentence with
a lot of grandiose words in it.
The third reason
journalism is stronger
is actually a reason I've
already covered stealthily.
It's about the data.
We have better data
than we used to.
Data sometimes gets fetishized,
and probably more often it
gets maligned as
somehow inhuman,
which is obviously silly.
Data is just the plural
of fact collected
in a way that allows for
meaningful comparisons
when it's done
right, but we really
do have better data and a
better picture of reality
than we used to.
Those studies I showed you about
the odds of escaping poverty
would not have been
possible before.
They're based on administrative
data that follow people over
many years and track their
earnings in a way that surveys
simply cannot do.
You cannot survey enough people,
and continue to follow them,
and expect them to answer
accurately about their earnings
in the way that
administrative data does.
We don't just have
administrative data.
We have all kinds of data from
the web that gives us insight
into what people are
doing and what people
are thinking as they are doing
it and as they are thinking it.
We've collaborated with Google
on a bunch of such projects,
including a fun piece
from Thanksgiving
about the regional
variations in recipes
that people search for
on Thanksgiving week.
Thanks to that, I
and readers know
what frog eye salad is, which
I do not recommend you eat.
And we know what
chocolate chess bars are,
which I do recommend you eat.
We also know that Jewish apple
cake is popular in Pennsylvania
and not at all Jewish.
The final reason that I
think journalism is stronger
is that the market says so.
The audience for
ambitious journalism
is larger than it was
only a short time ago.
The number of people who
read a typical big story
at the "Times" has increased
probably 50% or 100%
since I joined the
paper, and many of them
are paying for it, either
through a paper subscription
or an online subscription.
Beyond the "Times," a potpourri
of really good new publications
have arisen, replacing some
of the famous brands that
have faded.
"Quartz," "Vox," "Buzzfeed,"
"FiveThirtyEight"-- I already
mentioned "Slate."
And while the "Atlantic" and
the "New Yorker" are old names,
they're doing new things,
and they're doing them well.
Just as important,
readers are making clear
that they want more of the
new forms of journalism.
If you look at the list of the
most read stories on the "New
York Times" over
any extended period,
you'll notice a few
fascinating patterns.
First, of course there
are articles about diet,
and exercise, and
sex, and real estate,
but that's not what most of
the best read particles are.
Most of the best read
articles are about subjects
that no one would ever
describe as click bait,
but I find this pattern
may be even more important.
A disproportionate share of the
most read articles at the "New
York Times" are not
articles, at least not
in the traditional sense.
They're interactives, like the
ones I've been showing you.
They're maps.
They're photos.
They're essays.
They're videos.
They're Q&A's.
They're often highly
substantive pieces
of work about serious topics.
They're just not in
the form around which
we've traditionally organized
journalism-- blocks of text.
You see it not just with what
we're doing at "The Upshot."
You see it through
an Ebola explainer.
You see through ISIS videos.
You see it through things
we've done on "Game of Thrones"
and on how people age.
I'm not suggesting
that journalism abandon
the traditional
article, and if this
were a journalistic
audience, I'd
spend five minutes assuring
you I'm not suggesting that,
but I do think that readers
are telling us something here,
and I think we could do
a better job of listening
than we are doing.
The smartest, clearest
way to tell a story
isn't always the way we would
have told it a generation ago.
It's especially
important for journalism
to listen to this message and
to others, to be self critical,
and to be open to change,
because we really are
dealing with some challenges.
As I mentioned at the beginning,
our old business model
has disappeared, and we don't
know exactly what the new one
looks like.
On the one hand, I believe there
is a large market of people
who are willing to pay
for good information
about the world directly through
subscriptions or indirectly
through advertising,
but the fact
is that the best
journalism has depended
on cross subsidies for
decades, if not centuries.
In the second half
of the 20th century,
those cross subsidies
came thanks to local quasi
monopolies-- newspapers--
that could use the revenue
from retail, and help
wanted, and other advertising
to provide a public good--
information about society
that educated readers and that
was often expensive to compile.
It's not like that
information was
an entirely self
sustaining business
before the internet came along.
It was partially
self sustaining,
and it can continue to
be at least partially
self sustaining.
The main business
task facing journalism
is to think about what new
services and new revenue
might replace those
old cross subsidies.
The main journalistic task is
to think openly and creatively
about the new tools that we
have to use them to give readers
the clearest, most
accurate, most
meaningful picture of reality.
That's what journalism is.
It's all that it
has ever been in,
and it's what it will continue
to be, regardless of the form
in which it is delivered.
Thank you for having me and
thank you for listening.
I look forward to
your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
SIMON ROGERS: Thank you, David.
That was terrific.
I'm interested as a fellow
refugee from newspaper days--
you grew up as a reporter
working on media,
on newspapers, that
whole background.
There's deadlines
and everything.
And now you're at this
area, which is really
the cutting edge of the
most innovative end of what
is going across journalism.
What do you gain from those
days that you use every day now?
There are skills that you
learned in the land of print,
but that you use every day now.
DAVID LEONHARDT: I
think there's a culture
in traditional journalism
that is extremely
valuable-- a culture of
skepticism that I actually
think sometimes goes too far.
I do think the bar for positive
stories is too high sometimes.
But a culture of
skepticism, a culture of we
exist to give you what is the
most important information,
even if it isn't
always the thing
that readers want to hear.
We're going to have reporters
in Afghanistan, regardless
of the immediate
readership for that.
That, I think, is very useful,
because I think otherwise
some of the new
tools and new metrics
we have could cause us
to quickly just write
about the diet
stories, the exercise
stories, the things like that.
SIMON ROGERS: And what's
been the most difficult part
of this transition
to "The Upshot?"
What's the weirdest thing that
you do that you would never
have done before?
DAVID LEONHARDT: I think
the most traditional thing
is the frustration
that I have with myself
because I can't use these
new tools personally.
I can write those
long blocks of text.
I can edit those long blocks
of text, and I can be, I hope,
a useful partner
to my colleagues
who can make the
maps and who can
make the interactive
calculators,
and I can help them think
about how to present it,
and I can be that
first reader, but I
can't get into the workings
of those calculators
the same way I can get into
the workings of a sentence.
And I've struggled
a little bit with,
should I do the equivalent
of going back to school?
Should I go spend
a month, two weeks,
six months learning
some of those skills?
The thing that's hard is I still
won't be very good at them,
but I think I've landed on
the answer to that is yes.
I should learn some
of the basic tools,
because in the
course of doing so,
I will probably gain more
insight into the challenges
that they face.
SIMON ROGERS:
That's interesting,
because there's been
a lot debate this week
about the value of having
coders working in the news
room working next to reporters.
You're in an
environment where you're
working very closely with people
who can build things and create
interactives.
What would you say
in that debate?
Do you stand on the
side of bringing people
closer together?
DAVID LEONHARDT: Yeah,
strongly on the side
of having coders as part
of the entire operation.
Traditional journalistic
organizations
have the wrong mix
of talent, which
isn't to say those of us
who have the old skills have
useless skills, but
we have the wrong mix.
We have too many people whose
skills are like my skills,
and we have not enough
people whose skills
are a growing part of what
the "New York Times" does.
We're trying to change that.
We are changing
that, but I think
it's almost certainly the
case that we should change
more rapidly than we are.
SIMON ROGERS: So
when you're thinking
about what you're going to
run, what kind of audience
do you have in mind?
Who is "The Upshot" for?
DAVID LEONHARDT:
Smart non-experts.
That, to me, is always
the audience we want.
We want to be writing about
education reform for nurses
and health care
reform for teachers.
We want to write about
Dodd-Frank for engineers,
and we want to write about,
depending on what kind
of engineering you're talking
about, bridge structure
for Wall Street traders.
That is really what we want.
SIMON ROGERS: And in practice,
does it work out like that,
or do you find that you have--
is there an over preponderance
of policy wonks or specialists?
DAVID LEONHARDT: The
interesting thing--
so I'm generally skeptical
of win-win arguments.
I think most things
are not win-win.
They're some
combination of win-lose,
and you've got to look
for the net positive.
So feel free to take this
win-win argument with a grain
of salt if you want.
The interesting thing
that I've learned
is that, when you write for
smart non-experts in a way
that frames the debate and you
succeed, you get the experts,
because the experts care
about how smart non-experts
are viewing their world.
Think about this.
If you're an economist, you care
about how members of Congress
think about the economy.
If you're an economist, you care
about how the president reads
about your research if he does.
And so if you manage
to succeed in writing
for smart non-experts, you
end up writing for the experts
as well, because they want to
be part of that conversation.
SIMON ROGERS: So
one of the-- I'm
going to open this
up in a second,
but one of the
questions I want to ask
was there's a kind of tradition
in data journalism of openness,
and people publishing their
work, and being transparent.
How important is that, do
you think, to the field?
DAVID LEONHARDT: I
think that's important.
I think we should just be a
little bit careful that-- I
think it would not be
a good use of our time
if, after every story, we
added 25% of our time to put
all of our data on GitHub.
Now, to be clear, we put
a lot of stuff on GitHub,
and with our most
ambitious stuff
I think it's really
important that we do that.
But I also think that
there is always a trade
off between going deeper
in any one subject,
and going deeper for
experts, and spending time
on the next thing that is
going to reach an audience.
And so on the one
hand, I'm strongly
in favor of more transparency.
It's been one of the
hallmarks of "The Upshot."
We were not the first
people to publish
a model that tried to
use polls to predict
the outcomes of elections.
Nate Silver was
arguably the first,
although I think some
political scientists did it
for tiny audiences before that.
We were the first to
have a model like that
and publish all of
our back end code.
So if you want to come
in and say, whoa, I
think you guys are putting way
too much weight on recent polls
and not nearly enough weight
on polls from two months ago
and you're a political
scientist, you could do that.
SIMON ROGERS: Has there
been a response to that?
Do people come and use it
and do stuff with that?
DAVID LEONHARDT: Yeah, they do.
Again, relative--
SIMON ROGERS: How
valuable is that?
DAVID LEONHARDT:
Relative to the number
of people who have visited
any one of those stories I put
up there, it's a rounding
error, but it's a rounding
error that matters, because if
we got something wrong or maybe
better, if there was an idea to
pursue that we didn't realize,
people can go in
and say, hey, do
you realize there's this
other idea to pursue there.
And so it does matter.
It's part of this more
liquid market for truth.
SIMON ROGERS: Of course I'll
love to open it up to the room
now, because we don't
have an awful lot of time.
Who would like to go first?
What kind of
questions do we have?
AUDIENCE: There's a microphone.
SIMON ROGERS: There's a
microphone at the back.
I should point out
there is a microphone
at the back on the
right hand side.
My right, your left.
AUDIENCE: Hey, David.
Thanks for coming today.
I'm curious as you set
aside your editorial plans
to tell stories with
data, do you more often
start with a data set
you've come across
and try to figure out what
the story is, or do you
guys, as an editorial team,
think of what kind of story
do you want to tell, and then
go out and get the data to help
you tell that story?
DAVID LEONHARDT: I think there
are three main ways we do it,
and it's both of those
two, and then it's a third.
So sometimes we start
with a question.
One of our two launch
stories was a story
that compared the incomes of
the middle class in the United
States with the incomes-- the
median income in the United
States and incomes of the
10th, 20th, 40th, 80th, 90th
percentiles in the United
States with the trends
in about a dozen other
mostly wealthy countries.
And that started because I
felt like, why haven't I ever
read that piece?
That piece should
be doable, and yet I
had never read that piece.
Instead it was all
about per capita GDP,
which is average
instead of median,
and which has the
big problem that,
in a time of high and
rising inequality,
is arguably less indicative
of what the typical family is
doing.
So in that case, we
just had the sense
that data must be out there.
Let's just keep shaking trees
until-- and unless we find it
in a way that we're comfortable
with, and we found it.
Some other times we come across
a data set that just really
seems wonderful.
Some of that is conversations
we've had with you all here.
And then the third thing is we
have academics who come to us
and who say, I've
got this work coming.
It's not released yet,
but I'm happy to give you
an advanced copy of it so that
your data visualization folks
can work on it in advance.
So really it depends
on all of it.
Our goal is never to do things
for the sake of doing it.
We are not trying to be a
full service publication.
We're not trying to become
a replacement news source.
We are part of the
"New York Times,"
and we are very happy about that
and feel very good about that.
And if the "Times" is
already covering it in a way
and we feel like we don't
have anything to add,
we're not going to do it
just because we can do it
in a more data-ey way.
SIMON ROGERS: Could "The Upshot"
survive outside the "Times"
as its own thing?
DAVID LEONHARDT:
That's a good question.
I'm probably the last person
who should try to answer it,
but I here's how
I would answer it.
We would do many things
extremely differently
if we were trying to
survive outside the "Times."
What we try to do is we try to--
SIMON ROGERS: You mean
you'd be chasing traffic?
DAVID LEONHARDT:
We'd probably do more
to chase traffic, which there's
a positive side of chasing
traffic.
We would try to do more
writing about the things that
are already on reader's minds.
We would probably do
more to chase traffic.
We really would say, hey,
we need to have something
to say about this.
We cannot credibly be a
serious news organization if we
don't have something to say
about the debate over trade
in Congress.
Now, we actually
did have something
to say about the debate over
trade, but we didn't have to.
I also think that we just--
this is a management thing.
It may not be of
the most interest,
but we try to send a message
to people inside the "Times"
and even to outside
contributors, hey,
you don't need to work for us.
You don't need to be a
member of "The Upshot" staff
to work with us.
And so some of our
best work is done
by "New York Times" employees
who are not technically
members of "The Upshot."
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about the design process.
So you're a writer.
You've got writing staff.
You've got data vis guys
that can do anything.
They can do multi-dimensional
hyper spaces
with interactive
whatevers, right?
How do you design and
how do you think--
can you walk us through
the process of choosing
what to put into the data vis
and what interactions to do,
and how you target that for
your audience or your perceived
audience, because there's a
ton of stuff you could do,
but you choose not to.
Can you walk us through
that design process?
DAVID LEONHARDT: Yeah.
So we really try to
be form agnostic,
and this may say more
about our own need
to break some past habits
than anything else,
but really the habit at
newspapers and magazines
is everything is
about the article.
And everything but the article
exists to support the article,
and we've really, really
tried to break that.
And so what we
instead try to say
is, what is the best
way to tell this story?
And sometimes we
say, you know what?
This, if done right, could
be a front page story,
and having a front page
story in the "New York Times"
continues to have
a ton of value,
and so we're going to do it
in that traditional way that
will allow us to a
front page story,
but that means we need to have
certain things in the headline,
and we need to have
certain things in the lead,
and there's certain
things we need
to do in order to get that story
on the front page of the "New
York Times" and have all the
benefits that come with that.
So in addition, we're going
to create a second URL.
The thing I showed you
that the geolocating where
it guessed what county you were
in, that's an example of that.
We had a front page story, and
then we said, you know what?
We think we can write a
headline and have a graphic that
is substantially more
appealing to a digital audience
than we will need to do to
do the front page story,
and we're not going to
try to combine the two.
We're just going to
separate this thing off,
and we're totally
comfortable with that.
That thing that you
saw there I think
got 8x the traffic of the
traditional article, which
is really good for
us to remember,
because internally the
traditional article is still
the more important thing.
In any real sense
of the word, that
was the more important, more
influential form of journalism,
and that continues to require
some cultural adjustment
for us.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
For those of us working
with data a lot,
we all know how noisy, how
much selection bias there is,
and how easy it is to
make the wrong sort
of [? cost all ?] conclusion.
So how do you guys make
sure you gatekeep yourself
and not mislead the public?
DAVID LEONHARDT: That's
a really good question,
and it's a really important one.
First of all, I think it's
important to acknowledge
I'm sure we're not perfect.
It's part of the
reason why I like
what I described as this
newly liquid market for truth,
because I'm more confident
that, when we mess up,
we'll hear about the
fact that we messed up.
We also try to have a somewhat
different process than has
traditionally been the case.
So traditionally you
would have a reporter
write a story, an editor who
is expert with language--
actually, several editors who
are expert with language--
edit that story, but you would
not ever have a data editor.
And we don't have anything
formal that is a data editor,
but we're trying to
do that informally.
So we have two
people on our staff
who are legitimate
statisticians, who have
graduate degrees in statistics.
We have several
others of us who work
sort of amateur
statisticians, and what
we try to do is make sure that,
even when we're not publishing
the entire thing
on the internet,
we send around the spreadsheet
and we basically say to people,
hey, will you please kick the
tires on this spreadsheet.
Not just kick the
tires on whether we
used an active or passive
verb, but kick the tires
on whether the calculations we
did, the assumptions we made,
the conclusions we
came to were right,
and we try to hash out
a lot of that in slack,
and in conversations,
and in other places.
AUDIENCE: Has it
ever happened you
had to do some retraction, a
mistake you made in the past?
DAVID LEONHARDT:
What's the biggest data
mistake that we have made?
SIMON ROGERS: Should point
out that it's inevitable
that mistakes are
going to happen.
DAVID LEONHARDT: No,
it definitely is.
That's why I don't want
to duck the question.
So this isn't the most important
piece of journalism we've done,
but it got a lot of traffic.
We did a bunch of fan maps
using Facebook data for baseball
and basketball, and for
baseball, based on Facebook
likes where fans were-- and
for baseball and basketball,
we had the advantage that those
are really one-- MLB and NBA,
those are single companies.
They're not 30
competing companies,
whatever the lawyers for
major league baseball and NBA
may claim otherwise.
Those are single companies.
And so there's a certain
uniformity to the data.
We then turned to do it
for college football,
and college football
programs do not
have the same uniformity of
data, and so as a result,
I think there was a little
bit more variation than we
initially understood,
and we would
have included more
caveats when we
published it had we thought
about all of that in advance.
So these exams may be wrong.
In fact, I'll use fake schools
so I don't get it wrong.
State University doesn't
have a separate Facebook
page for its football team.
It just has an athletics page.
University of State does
have a dedicated Facebook
page for its football team.
That will probably influence
how many likes the two get,
and as a result, will
influence the map,
and we could have done
a better job of making
that clearer than we did.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about the quality
of data presentation at
the "New York Times."
It seems that the "New
York Times" has always
maintained the highest
standard in the industry about,
not only just the data, also
the presentation of the data.
It's always consistent and
designed in a beautiful way.
I think that's an
area that Google
has [? personal appeal ?],
somewhat struggle about.
And so how do you enforce that?
Is there a committee,
or is it built
into the collective
consciousness,
or is there-- you are
enforce a set of tools.
Or how did you achieve that?
DAVID LEONHARDT: Thank
you, first of all.
There is an enormously
talented graphics department
that has become increasingly
important over time.
It's run by someone named
Steve Duenes, who really is one
the most important
people at the newspaper.
And it is a department that
has a really strong culture
of excellence.
So if you notice when
the "Times" has something
successful like the
dialect quiz, which
is the most viewed page in
the history of the "New York
Times," we don't then
immediately go and do
five other versions of it.
You haven't seen seven other
quizzes about different forms
of language for the "Times."
Now, that has some downsides
if we're being honest about it.
That is not a traffic
maximizing decision,
but I think there is this real
culture on the graphic staff
that what they want to be
doing is they consistently
want to be pushing
the envelope and doing
new things and excellent
things, and they never
want to get bored.
They always want to be learning.
It is the most collaborative
department at the paper.
It's why you often see five and
six by lines on these things.
It's a department
that really has,
I think, a lot of the best
forms of team culture.
And I think that department,
which really started
in many ways as a backwater--
the graphics apartment was not
one of the most important
departments in the "New York
Times" 20 years ago-- is
really responsible for that.
And what we're now
trying to figure out
as an organization-- and
"The Upshot" in some ways
is an experiment to think
about, because we work very
closely with that
department-- is
how do we take more of
that digital sensibility
that they have and spread
it around the whole paper.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SIMON ROGERS: I love
the idea of a committee
to decide on visuals.
That would be great.
AUDIENCE: Kind of a follow
up about presentation.
So you can kind of infamously
misinform people with graphics.
DAVID LEONHARDT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Personally I think
that the "New York Times" has
always done a really
good job with this,
but I'm wondering if you
guys do any work to validate
that that's true.
So for example,
I loved the piece
you showed where I was asked to
draw the line of what I thought
the relationship between
income and college attendance
was, because it sort of forced
me to validate my assumptions,
but when you design
an interactive map,
do you guys do anything to
validate your assumption
that readers actually
are understanding this,
or they are able to
draw meaning from it,
or maybe they're being
perhaps misinformed,
or drawing conclusions that
aren't supported by the data?
DAVID LEONHARDT: Can I answer
the question with a question?
What's a hypothetical way
that we could validate that?
AUDIENCE: That's actually
why I'm asking you.
I was kind of hoping you guys
knew more about this than me,
but I could imagine,
for example,
doing survey research
following up.
If there is something
that was factually true
and you try to present it
graphically, after the fact,
were people able to
accurately answer
a question about that factual?
DAVID LEONHARDT: That's
a really fun idea.
No, we haven't obviously.
So this you draw it is in
some ways an early attempt
to try to do that.
We should try that.
We should think about giving
people-- it would be tricky.
I'm sure some readers
would have no interest.
Others would feel that
we were taking them back
to grade school, but
my guess is some,
if we did it in a
sufficiently fun way
and made it feel like a game,
would be willing to do it.
And it would be interesting
to see whether, in fact, we
got it right.
I do think that social
media and the emails we
receive from readers provides
an informal version of that.
I do think we've
all noticed times
where we see a reaction
to an article and think,
that's not what I meant.
But I think would be good
to make it more rigorous
and fun as well, so thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID LEONHARDT:
The only postscript
I'd add to that is I agree
charts can really mislead
people-- so can
quotations, so can
some of the traditional
forms of journalism.
And my guess is everyone in
this room agrees with that.
It's sometimes
something that I want
to remind some of my colleagues
as traditional journalists--
that it's not like, oh
yes, you can lie with data,
but you can't lie with
five person on the street
interviews.
AUDIENCE: I think
a classic example
of that is the Iraq
WMD thing, where,
despite a lot of reporting,
very little of it graphical,
the American public
overwhelmingly
believed that Iraq was
involved in 9/11, despite tons
of reporting by the "Times"
and other places that
made no connection whatsoever.
DAVID LEONHARDT: Right.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID LEONHARDT: Thank you.
SIMON ROGERS: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
DAVID LEONHARDT: Hi.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
earlier that it
was important for journalists
to learn more technical skills,
and I was wondering, in
your news organization,
do you find that people in other
departments have the same need
or could build more
technical skills?
For example, business
strategists, or people who
just need to understand the
new digital ecosystem in news.
Do you find that that is
lacking in your organization,
or do you feel people are very
well prepared for the changes?
Thanks.
DAVID LEONHARDT: Thank you.
Most journalistic organizations
have this church state wall
between business
and the newsroom,
and so I actually spend
relatively little time
interacting with folks
on the business side.
There are ways in
which we've decided
we're comfortable
with some new mingling
that we weren't
comfortable with before.
We don't want the person who's
trying to sell advertisements
to a car company ever talking
with our reporter who covers
the car industry, but
the "Times'" revenue
has become increasingly from
readers and decreasingly
from advertisers, which of
course, is both the good news
and bad news story.
Our revenue from readers is up.
Our revenue from
advertisers is down.
I do think we want the person
who's writing about the auto
industry interacting with
the readers who are reading
about the auto
industry, and that
has led to a little
bit more collaboration.
I think the short answer
to your question is yes.
I think that journalism
has traditionally
had relatively little
investment in technical skills,
in data skills, and I think
there is now a real realization
that we need to change that.
Some of that is because I think
the returns to specialization
in journalism have really risen.
I bet you notice this at
the "Guardian" as well.
Generalists used to be really
what was valued in journalism.
You'd drop someone in a place.
They have the ability to
go describe what happened,
and summarize it in
a thousand words,
and come tell you what you need
to know at the end of the day.
That is much more
commoditized than it used
to be-- what actually happened.
And so there are many
more returns to specialty
than there used to be there.
It's much better.
As a reader, what I
want is a journalist
who knows something about
a subject that I don't know
and can teach me
about it, and I think
this increased investment
in technical skills
is part and parcel
of the way in which
the returns to specialization
have increased.
SIMON ROGERS: How
long do you think
before data is not considered
a specialism in the newsroom?
We talked about this
earlier, the idea that
actually in the
future everybody will
be a [INAUDIBLE]
journalist, but you
wouldn't say an internet
journalist now, would you?
Every reporter does
their research online?
DAVID LEONHARDT: No, and
we're trying to get there.
I apologize.
I showed you all of
these in desktop.
We, now, often when
we're working these,
work in the mobile
view, because that's
how slightly more than half
the people are going to see it,
and so we no longer talk
about mobile journalism.
I think that we will get
there with data journalism,
and I think we
are not there yet.
In a way, I'm just
quoting something
you said to me
earlier back to you,
but I think if you took the
best data journalists now
and plopped them in a
traditional newsroom,
you'd have all
kinds of problems.
SIMON ROGERS: It
would be a nightmare.
DAVID LEONHARDT: It
SIMON ROGERS: All of
those egos together.
DAVID LEONHARDT: It
would be a nightmare.
SIMON ROGERS: Horrific.
DAVID LEONHARDT: I also
think that we're really
making progress.
When I see Nate Cohn, my
colleague on the upshot, who
is, I think, one of
the most interesting
political journalists alive,
talking to Jonathan Martin,
the national political
correspondent
for the "Times,"
who I think is one
of the most
interesting journalists
alive-- their skills have very
little overlap in the Venn
diagram, but they realize they
each have something to learn
from each other,
and I'm not sure
that would have been the
case even a few years ago.
SIMON ROGERS: I think
we can take probably
two more questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi David,
thanks so much for coming.
Let me lower this real quick.
I wanted to follow up on your
point on local news coverage,
and I echo the concern-- the
decline of local news coverage
in this state of media, but
watching your presentation
it really struck me
that "The Upshot"
is doing local journalism,
that you're drilling down
to the county level.
And so where do you see
these local newspapers
who are struggling
not only with funding,
but with the lack of tools to
be able to create something
like this.
How do they continue to
do local data journalism?
Or do you start seeing the
"New York Times" and all
of the other publications
that you mentioned
who are doing data journalism
well who are actually
national organizations starting
to take on that role of doing
good local journalism?
DAVID LEONHARDT: I hadn't
thought about that,
but you're right.
There is a way in which we are
doing some local journalism.
I don't think it can replace
truly local journalism.
I think truly local
journalism requires
a kind of expertise
and specialization
that we will never
have about-- you
saw I didn't even
know what county we
were standing in here.
Here's a theory I have, which
could be completely wrong.
I think that there
is an untapped market
for really useful,
quite local information
out there that eventually
someone is going to figure out.
I don't think-- I think the
mistake that journalists have
made so far is they
think it looks more
like the local journalism of
old than it actually does,
but I think about myself.
I would gladly pay
some amount of money
that is kind of
significant-- $20 a month,
$30 a month-- for something
that was super local, and smart,
and maybe even a highly
data based about where
I live in suburban Maryland.
Something that
essentially every morning
delivered me information about
the metro system in Washington.
I'm a big public transit user.
But also about roads, something
that really got into stuff
about schools,
and any data there
is about schools,
which there's a lot of.
Stuff that was able to do
much more on youth sports.
There's actually a
lot of information
that I want that,
yes, some of it
you get through things like
Waze and other things like that,
but much of it looks
more journalistic.
And I think there is a market
for that that, if someone
figures out, would
have the potential
to then pay for even
four reporters--
we reporters aren't that
expensive-- even four reporters
to cover, say,
Bethesda, Maryland.
And I have some
hope-- it probably
won't look exactly the
way I've described it.
It probably requires a little
bit more entrepreneurial rigor
than I'm able to
bring to it, but I
do think there is this gap
between the hyper local
information that people
would actually pay for
and what local journalism
is now trying to provide,
and I'm hopeful that
someone figures that out
in a way that strengthens
local journalism.
SIMON ROGERS: So this is
kind of related to that.
So 2012 is possibly the first
data journalism election, what
does 2016 hold in this field?
What are we going
to see not just
from what you're going to
offer, but across the field?
DAVID LEONHARDT:
Through much of this,
I've been wishing that
my colleagues Amanda Cox
and Kevin Quealy,
who I mentioned,
were sitting here to answer
these questions, because they'd
be really good at it.
This is a question which I wish
Nate Cohn, who I mentioned,
was here.
So I'm copying from
my colleague here.
Let me acknowledge that.
I think the fact
that 2008 and 2012
were relatively
predictable elections
have led to an over confidence
about how much we actually
know about the 2016 election.
The last three
elections-- we had
two with incumbent presidents,
which from a data standpoint
are just vastly easier to
model and to think about,
and we had one
that wasn't close.
We had the most unpopular
president in many of our life
times-- those of us who
weren't old enough to remember
Richard Nixon or Jimmy Carter.
And so it clearly just
wasn't going to be close.
You had a tanking economy
and an unpopular war,
and there was no
model that was going
to say that John McCain
was going to win.
Then 2012, all the
models again pointed
to Obama, an incumbent president
running for reelection.
2016 is going to be different.
There is huge uncertainty
about what the economy is
going to be doing.
It's probably going to
be sort of grinding along
in a way that doesn't point
toward defeat or victory
for the incumbent
party, and we are not
going to have an incumbent
president on the ballot.
And as a result of that,
and when you overlay that
with stuff that I've talked
with Hal about in great depth,
the real challenges
facing polling--
the change in polling-- I
think it's really possible
that, unlike the
last few elections,
we're going to have an
election in which, three
weeks out, there's still
substantial uncertainty
about the outcome.
And even if we
don't have that, I
think we will have much more
uncertainty three months,
six months, nine months out
than I think many people today
realize.
SIMON ROGERS: So I'm sure we'll
be working on that together,
and we've had some
partnerships in the past,
but what do you
want from Google?
What can we do to make
your world easier?
DAVID LEONHARDT: So I
mentioned the polling,
the changes in polling.
Basically the polling
industry, which
has this phenomenal
record of success
over its modern
history dependent
on a landline telephone--
there's a small problem there.
And we also have this problem
that a lot of government data
relies on surveys,
and people, not just
because decline of
the landline, people
are just less willing to answer
surveys than they used to be.
There's also a desire
among some in Washington
to cut the funding for
government surveys.
And so there are all of these
forms of traditional data
that are becoming less good.
And while I am optimistic
about the potential for data
to become better
and while I actually
think it is becoming
better, I also
think it's worth acknowledging
that a lot of that data that
lets us understand the world,
that helps people lead better
lives is now in private hands.
It's in your hands.
It's in Facebook's hands.
It's in other hands.
And so I understand you
all are a private company.
I understand your obligation
is to your shareholders,
but I do think there is a public
obligation and a public trust
that companies like Google--
and Google in particular--
have to think about
ways to make sure
that we're able to
use all of the data
that you're collecting
to make us smarter
about the world where we live
and ultimately really allow
that world to be a better place.
SIMON ROGERS: Thank
you very much.
DAVID LEONHARDT: Thank
you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]